[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story unwise but not illegal
Phillip Schofield admits lying about an
affair with a much younger male
colleague at this morning and leaves ITV
with immediate effect
the broadcaster confirms his resignation
and says they are deeply disappointed
and feel badly let down
also tonight killed by his next of kin
ten month old Finley Bowden murdered by
his parents who lied to Social Services
and expressed No Remorse you lied that
he had covered so that no one would see
him and remove him from your care and in
doing so you subjected your own baby son
to unimaginable cruelty
claim the premise drug harm their babies
are dismissed by a judge after an appeal
by pharmaceutical companies and the
government
grounded an exclusive report on why new
RAF Pilots are waiting up to a year to
get their wings
recession would be worth the risk to
bring down inflation the chancellor
tells Sky News he'll do whatever it
takes to curb Rising prices
the doctor will have to see many more
people now Sky News reveals GPS at
breaking point in the most deprived
areas
plus mid-flight Panic what happened when
a passenger opened a plane's emergency
exit
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
foreign
[Music]
good evening he's one of the most famous
faces on television but tonight Phillip
schofield's facing an uncertain
professional future the presenter of
this morning has admitted lying about an
affair he had with a much younger man
who worked with him on the program he
said his affair was unwise but not
illegal and his now left ITV with
immediate effect bringing an end to his
career of more than 20 years with the
broadcaster tonight a spokesperson for
his former employer said Philip made
assurances to us which he now
acknowledges were untrue and we feel
badly let down here's our arts and
entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer hello good morning and welcome
to your Tuesday this morning good
morning right we've got a pack show for
you today Phil Vickery after five
decades on our screens Phillip Schofield
was not only one of the best paid
presenters on British TV he was much
loved his was an easy style built on
warmth and relatability but within the
space of a week not only has he said
goodbye to the show he's worked on for
more than 20 years now also dropped by
his agent and accused of trying to
silence stories about his alleged
inappropriate behavior claims he
exploited his position to have a
relationship with a staff member much
Junior and younger than him on this
morning all the while he was married in
response to tabloid Revelations he first
apologized to his employer ITV the first
thing I want to say is I'm deeply sorry
for having lied to them and to many
others about a relationship that I had
with someone working on this morning I
did have a consensual on off
relationship with a younger male
colleague at this morning contrary to
speculation whilst I met that man when
he was a teenager and was asked to help
him to get into television it was only
after he started to work on the show
that it became more than a just it was
only after he started to work on the
show that it became more than just a
friendship that relationship was unwise
but not illegal it is now over
Phillip Schofield has nine lives and
he's run out there's nine lives now you
know we had qgate we've had you know the
you know him coming out declaring his
true personality
um his relationship with Holly uh
Willoughby has disappeared um his fans
don't you know you know don't believe in
him anymore
um it's just not a good day for Sophie
or Brandon whether he'll ever recover I
don't know
now we can't start Today's Show without
paying tribute to the man who spent the
last two decades sitting on this morning
sofa Phillip Schofield so following
weeks of speculation of a rift between
Schofield and his co-presenter Holly
Willoughby at the start of this week
this morning's goodbye to their former
star turn was brief perhaps aware of
what was to come
from his days back in the broom cupboard
presenting kids TV it is with great
speed that the industry we've watched
him grow up in has turned against him
and I could not have done it
if it hadn't been you
um
so afterwards I don't know but no
there's no one I'm not I'm not rushing
out to anybody well there was a wave of
support behind when Phillip Schofield
came out now news of his alleged
predatory behavior has seen the star
dropped like a stone a spectacular Fall
From Grace Katie Spencer's Sky News
well our correspondent Saba choudhary is
in West London for us tonight and Saba
what's been the reaction from ITV this
evening
good evening Jillian well in the last
half an hour also ITV have shared this
statement with Sky News we are deeply
disappointed by the admissions of Deceit
made tonight by Phillip Schofield the
relationships we have with those we work
with are based on trust Philip made
assurances to us which he now
acknowledges were untrue and we feel
badly let down we accept his resignation
from ITV and therefore can confirm that
he will not be appearing on ITV as had
previously been stated so this really
does look like the end of Phillip
schofield's relationship with ITV after
a relationship spanning back decades
although this isn't the only
relationship or long-standing
relationship that has now come to an end
his talent agency a company called ymu
have also dropped Philip Schofield
saying that they have decided to part
ways with the 61 year old presenter
after some new information and came to
light this week which contradicted what
Schofield had previously told ymu and
also the external advisors they'd
brought in to help him earlier the past
few weeks now Philip schofield's future
really does look like there are question
marks around his future for sure but we
are unlikely Jillian to see him
presenting anytime soon
Saba thank you
the parents of a baby boy who was
murdered during lockdown on Christmas
Day in 2020 have been jailed for Life
ten month old Finley Bowden was killed
by his mother and father after
sustaining more than 130 injuries in
what's been described as a series of
Savage and brutal attacks
Shannon Marsden and Stephen Bowden were
heavy cannabis users who lied repeatedly
to Social Services Finley had originally
been placed under a care order but
despite the local Council warning of the
risk of serious harm a Family Court
ruled that he should be returned to his
parents a warning Catherine of itazi's
report contains distressing details
these were the videos Finley bowden's
parents wanted the world to see
but behind closed doors Shannon Marsden
and Stephen Bowden beat bruised and
burnt their baby's son inflicting more
than 130 separate injuries that led to
severe infections
Finney died on Christmas Day 2020 just
10 months old
having brutally assaulted Finley on at
least two occasions you continued to
abuse him and you lied that he had
covered so that no one would see him and
remove him from your care and in doing
so you subjected your own baby son to
unimaginable cruelty Finland was taken
into Care at Birth because of his
parents drug use but at eight months old
he was returned to them the court heard
the couple lied to their families and to
Social Services saying they were clean
that their home in Chesterfield was safe
but under two months later Finley was
dead and police found a family home like
this full of rubbish smelling of urine
and cannabis with a moldy milk bottle
next to the bed
the heartbreaking reality is that
Finley's last days
would have been spent in immense pain a
fact that would have been abundantly
clear to both parents
they knew that they were responsible for
those injuries and instead of doing the
right thing and taking Finley to get
urgent medical care
they took him shopping in Chesterfield
town center as though nothing were wrong
this was that outing captured on CCTV it
was Christmas Eve and the last time
Finley was seen alive a safeguarding
review is already underway because there
are questions as to why a family court
said that it was safe for Finley to
return to his parents immediately in
full time when a social worker had
recommended a gradual return over four
months as well as regular drugs tests
for his parents as they were sentenced
today at Derby Crown Court Finley's
parents showed no emotion but a
statement was read out written by their
families who called the couple monsters
although we will never forget Finley
they said we will forget you
Catherine of Tootsie Sky News Derby
families fighting for compensation over
damage allegedly caused by the hormone
pregnancy drug primidos have been dealt
a blow after their appeal was struck out
by the high court campaigners began the
legal action after using the drug
between the 1950s and 1970s claiming it
caused serious birth defects the
manufacturers have always denied the
allegations but an independent review
found that primadol should have been
taken off the market and three years ago
the government offered an apology here's
our home editor Jason Farrell
Christine was hoping to get compensation
for living life with a shortened arm she
believes it was caused when she was in
the womb by the drug primidos which her
mother was given by her GP to use as a
pregnancy test
but today's ruling against the claimants
is yet another setback for a campaign
that has been running for over 40 years
enough is enough how it does don't mean
to be too melodramatic but it does feel
like they're just waiting for us all to
die you know us babies are dying younger
than we seemingly should
um our our mothers our parents are
getting older and
how much longer is this going to go on
Christine was among campaigners who
attended Court as the manufacturer and
Government tried to strike out their
claim based on the fact that they didn't
have enough evidence nor the funding to
go to trial Mrs Justice Yip agreed
saying the claimants have only limited
funding through the funds of the
association charitable fundraising and
crowdfunding there's no evidence that
they're likely to secure the funds
necessary to progress their claim she
said it hadn't been disproved that the
drug damaged babies in the womb but nor
could the claimants prove that it had
the alarm about the drug was first
raised by scientist Isabel gal in 1967
her research in nature magazine
suggested a higher number of babies with
spinal defects had been born to women
who'd used the pregnancy test drug but
the drug remained on the market for
years until further studies pointed to a
link with other abnormalities in the
fetus and a warning appeared on the
packet in 1975 saying primitus must not
be taken unless it's certain that the
patient is not pregnant a review team in
July 2020 led by baroness kublish found
the drug had caused avoidable harm and
should have been removed from the market
years sooner the government apologized I
want to issue a full apology to the uh
to the those who've suffered and their
families but having apologized the
government's never properly explained
why it subsequently found itself on the
side of the manufacturers hiring lawyers
to ensure that this case never got to a
full hearing
the reputation of the manufacturer Bayer
has been upheld by this ruling but the
value of a government apology is much
diminished campaigners like Christine
say they will fight on Jason Farrell Sky
News
Sky News has learned that the UK's
trainee military Pilots will have to
wait up to a year to start flying
lessons the RAF says it's working to fix
problems within the system that have
prompted some recruits to quit the
revelations come as the UK has just
offered flying training to the
ukrainians our defense and security
editor Deborah Haynes has this exclusive
report
graduation time for the raf's newest
offices
but anyone hoping to become a pilot may
have up to a year to wait for flying
lessons to start commanders are working
to fix chronic problems with the
training system that's caused huge
delays and even prompted some recruits
to quit speaking anonymously one such
trainee Aviator told Sky News I and the
majority of aircrew are resentful at
having had our time wasted through
shoddy organization in a service that
doesn't value its Personnel I'm not
alone in feeling massively let down by
senior officers after we've given up so
much personally to serve UK security
I left because I no longer had an Air
Force I was proud to serve Elite
documents seen by Sky News reveals the
mfts or military flying training system
while improving remains under strain
of 770 trainy air crew almost two-thirds
490 people are either between courses or
on hold waiting for a slot to open up
as part of efforts to reduce log dams it
said the RAF plans to optimize the
pipeline by temporarily reducing the
inflow of trainees to EFT or Elementary
flying training
it's a move that may mean holds of up to
12 months the RAF insists that the
experience of those doing Flying
training here at cramwell and elsewhere
is finally improving that the capacity
of the training pipeline has been shrunk
over time to cut costs in line with
reductions to the size of the Air Force
it means it's less resilient and one new
shock could knock the whole system off
course again
an RAF spokesperson said criticism of
the system focused on individual views
and historical issues ignores the
variety of proactive measures that have
been introduced and that both holding
and training times have reduced and will
continue to do so but the UK has just
announced plans to help train Ukrainian
Pilots to the RAF says this won't impact
on British flying courses others are not
so sure
Deborah Haynes Sky News
the chancellor has insisted he's
comfortable with Britain being plunged
into recession if that's what it takes
to bring down inflation in an exclusive
interview with Sky News Jeremy Hunt said
he would fully support the bank of
England hiking interest rates
potentially towards 5.5 percent as it
battles higher than expected prices
here's our economics and data editor Ed
Conway
we will halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt it was the first of Richie
sunac's five pledgers as prime minister
halving inflation now the chancellor
says he's happy for Britain to go
through more economic pain if that's
what it takes to do it it comes after
higher than expected inflation data
prompted markets to lift their interest
rate expectations to 5.5 percent
something that could push the UK into a
slump are you comfortable with the bank
of England doing whatever it takes to
bring down inflation even if that
potentially would precipitate that
recession that you've almost just
avoided yes because in the end even if
there's the inflation is a source of
instability we have to support the bank
of England in the difficult decisions
that they take and what I would say Ed
is that when the Prime Minister
announced that it was his objective to
halve inflation in January there were
some people who who derided that they
said well it's automatic inflation's
going to come down in any anyhow there's
nothing automatic about bringing down
inflation it is a big task but we must
deliver it and we will even if it means
precipitating a recession well um we
will deliver this task and we will make
sure that the government plays its part
the bank of England plays its part but
it is not a trade-off between tackling
inflation and recession in the end the
only path to sustainable growth is to
bring down inflation one of the main
reasons Liz trust and quasi quattang
were booted out of office last year was
that after the mini budget there was
Financial chaos and interest rate
expectations went up to six percent rusi
sunak and Jeremy Hunt's main claim was
that they were going to stabilize the
economy but now with interest rate
expectations back up to five and a half
percent even that is under question
the prime minister's five pledges were
supposed to be easy the problem is that
solving number one halving inflation
might mean failing number two growing
the economy Ed Conway Sky News
Sky News analysis of NHS data has
revealed the extent of the pressure felt
by doctors in surgeries in England and
Wales one in every five GP practices has
closed since 2013 and those that remain
open are increasingly stretched thin
with the most deprived areas under the
most strain almost three and a half
thousand GPS quit general practice last
year the highest on record our data and
forensics correspondent Tom Cheshire has
the detail
more patience fewer GPS
new Sky analysis paints a grim picture
especially in the most deprived and most
diverse areas how much extra pressure a
GDP is facing it is just constant that's
all you just can't switch off you're
always thinking about that patient that
you could have done more for you're
always thinking about other patients
that you need to deal with there is a
constant pressure to do things 274
patients have phoned us already today
that may be 700 on a Monday and they
just aren't 274 slots that we can find
for those patients to get what they need
today
analysis of the latest figures by the
Sky News data and forensics team shows
what GPS are up against this is the
number of practices in England and well
steady growth from the mid 80s onwards
but then nearly one in five have shot
over the last decade on top of that
there are fewer GPS here in Black
they're dealing with a lot more patience
in yellow even since 2016. the problem
gets worse depending where you are
specifically how wealthy the area you
live in is the most deprived areas here
on the left have the fewest GPS per
patient and even within those deprived
areas GP serving people from Minority
backgrounds are the most stretched South
Asian communities have nearly a thousand
more patients per GP than white
communities and GPS from across the
country have been in touch to talk about
the pressure and we already have
collapsed in all fairness and if so
trying to tell you that we haven't
collapsed they're absolutely wrong we're
a bucket full of holes so you are
putting in lots of trainees they're
taking on the training post but they're
leaving this has been coming for about
10 years I've been a GP 30 years I think
the last 10 years this has been an
increasing problem
um and it's just not been addressed
properly
the Department of Health and Social care
told us that they were investing in
primary care and that there were 500
more doctors working in general practice
compared to a year ago for the GPS we
spoke to that is not nearly enough to
plug the holes that already exist Tom
Cheshire Sky News
a man has been jailed for life with a
minimum term of 32 years for murdering
his partner's 15-month-old son
Jake Drummond conducted a sadistic
campaign of abuse which led to the
murder of Jacob Lennon Jacob's mother
Louisa Lennon who also jailed for 10
years for allowing his death
an inquest into the death of a female
officer Cadet has concluded the Army
missed opportunities to prevent her
taking her own life 21 year old Olivia
perks was found dead in her room at
Sandhurst Military Academy in 2019 a
pre-inquest hearing found she was the
victim of gross sexual misconduct by
senior soldiers
the Army says it's deeply sorry for what
it calls systemic and individual
failings
British Airways has canceled dozens of
flights for a second day following an
I.T failure at Heathrow Airport the
total number canceled now stands at 175
the majority have been short haul
flights but ba says the issue has now
been resolved
British cycling has announced a
permanent ban on transgender women
taking part in all-female competitive
events they will now race in a new open
category in a move which the governing
body says has been taken in a spirit of
fairness our Sports correspondent Rob
Harris has more
Elite female cyclists racing through the
Essex Countryside on a day when who can
compete in female races was restricted
to those born female by British cycling
their boss announcing a new open
category for anyone identifying as
non-binary or assigned male at Birth
it's very difficult it's device if it's
emotive it's affecting human beings the
science isn't certain so why go against
inclusivity we want to give direction we
want to remove the uncertainty and
certainly the athletes have been
affected by this uncertainty created
over the past few months
um I'm really sorry for the anxiety for
the upset
transgender women had been able to race
in women's events if their testosterone
was below a particular level but that
policy was suspended 14 months ago amid
a backlash
this transgender cyclist had won races
competing as a male while transitioning
she was blocked from her potential debut
in a women's event and now Emily Bridges
feels banned calling British cycling a
failed organization
she called the new policy a violent act
adding I don't even know if I want to
race my bike anymore the danger and
everything that would come with racing
makes it a pretty hard thing to justify
to myself
Emily and a number of athletes are
clearly affected by this policy but what
we wanted to provide at this point in
time is The Clarity on the direction of
travel Clarity welcome by female Riders
who did not want to compete against
anyone with potential benefits of male
puberty
sport we're talking about
identity
a meal
advancory otherwise you are
discriminating against women and girls
but sport can seem to be discriminating
against those already facing
discrimination in wider Society having
an open category trans women and not men
and it's really taken away what the
future is for our young people involved
in sports as well and we're not actually
seeing conversations around the research
we're not seeing conversations around
being more inclusion but exclusion is
also the policy of Athletics and
Aquatics globally now International
cycling Chiefs have to decide whether to
follow Britain by prioritizing sporting
fairness over inclusivity Rob Harris Sky
News
a passenger has opened an emergency exit
door during a flight in South Korea
forcing the crew to land while it was
still open the plane was at an altitude
of 700 feet and carrying almost 200
passengers when the incident happened
Milena vaselenovich reports
of degu
passengers holding on against the force
of the wind luckily wearing seat belts
as the plane was minutes from Landing
it likely saved their lives when a man
opened the emergency door as the jet was
descending
still the pilots managed to land safely
and the man was arrested on board his
motivation unclear but his actions
injuring 12 people most suffering
breathing difficulties
it's an outcome that could have been so
much worse nine people died in 1989 when
the cargo door of this 747 blew off on
route to New Zealand twenty thousand
feet above the Pacific
the South Korean plane was just 700 feet
above ground when the incident happened
which meant the passengers could breathe
but it also meant the emergency door
could be opened whereas on higher
altitudes the cabin pressure seals its
shot but whether the airline could have
done anything to prevent this will now
form part of the investigation into what
was a very close call Milena
vasilinovich Sky News
I just want to bring you some breaking
news now the former prime minister Boris
Johnson has spoken for the first time
about further allegations that he
attended illegal Gatherings during
lockdown cabinet office officials have
sent details about events held in
checkers and Downing Street after they
reviewed Mr Johnson's official diary
while speaking exclusively to Sky News a
short time ago our U.S correspondent
James Matthews put the new allegations
to Mr Johnson during a visit to the
United States
millions of a long down signal an end to
your political career
Mr Johnson what are these what's up what
are the WhatsApp messages tell us about
your behavior during lockdown
do they further impugn your integrity
sir
is your political career over Mr Johnson
Mr Johnson do these lockdown claims
finish your political career
so you're being paid a lot of money on a
speaking engagement in the United States
people in the UK might want to hear you
speak on a matter that matters to them
I'm gonna be a customer so please stop
by
Mr Johnson will you be Mr Johnson will
you be further embarrassed by your
WhatsApp messages during lockdown
will they further impure your integrity
sir
Mr Johnson
what did your constituents have to gain
from your meeting with Donald Trump
so Johnson you have form in terms of
breaking the law on Covert have you
broken it again
no and I I've been here to talk about
Ukraine that's what I've been doing and
why wouldn't you talk about covert
you've been accused of breaking the law
in checkers and at Downing Street did
you no but uh you're like
um it's there if it's proved that you
did are you finished as a politician
the answer is that
um
as I said before there was absolutely no
uh
rule breaking and you know
what proof do you have of that
well look you know those who want to
make allegations should make allegations
and so far nobody has and you're my
honest view I think this whole thing is
completely nonsensical and look I've got
to check in for a flight now this whole
thing is a load of absolute nonsense
um
I think he was absurd that it was
decided to pass entries in my diary to
the uh
police what do these entries say what do
these entries say they merely record the
events in my uh in my day meeting
friends at Checkers when you shouldn't
have been absolutely not
absolutely not and that will be
demonstrated what did they demonstrate
and I've got nothing more to say
I'm asking you very politely to back up
please thank you very much
we won't yeah do you understand yeah
okay thank you I appreciate that
so yeah sorry yeah if you want an
interview you know happily talk to you
this hopefully is a load of nonsense
from beginning to end and we've made
that clear in the statements that I've
issued
um I think that it's ridiculous
that elements in my diary should be
Cherry Picked and handed over to
the police to the Privileges committee
without even
anybody having the the basic common
sense
to ask me what these entries referred to
what do they refer to there is
absolutely nothing in those entries that
constitutes uh rule breaking during
covid restrictions okay mingling with
friends at Checkers that is absolutely
not what those diary entries show that
is not what those diary entries show and
the whole thing is totally nonsensical
who is trying to stitch you up Mr
Johnson who well who do you think is
trying to set you up
who do you think is trying to set you up
yeah and don't just let's let's go let's
go who is trying to set you up Sir is it
Richie sunak look I think
he's from Sky News he's from Sky News
he's been he's entitled to to ask me
questions and I'm going to tell you I
just think it's totally nonsense School
and
um bizarre that
there are tens of thousands of entries
in the the prime minister of Derry I've
never seen these things before because I
looked through it
um none of them constitute a breach of
the rules during during covid during
that and they weren't during lockdown
they were doing other periods of the of
the restrictions none of them
constituted reach of the rules none of
them involve socializing it is total
nonsense and
um I find it extraordinary absolutely
extraordinary that these things are
handed over
by I don't know quite what Authority the
the cabinet office or whoever to the
Privileges committee and to the police
without any attempt to establish what
these things actually mean or what they
refer to with me
and I can assure you that I can ensure
the public that they're all incompletely
innocent and within the rules and you
know you talk about a stitch up you talk
about you smoking advice
you said originally you're being
stitched up by whom Richie
that
um
somebody somewhere thinks it's sensible
to do this I don't take care of us let's
talk of a skip fire in the Tory party
would you encourage that and do you see
that as a potential comeback for you
oh that's former prime minister Boris
Johnson there speaking to our U.S
correspondent James Matthews returning
from a visit to the United States in
which he said it's absurd that um
that they passed
details from his diary entries to the
police
um the whole thing is a load of nonsense
from beginning to end and nothing that
he did constitutes rule breaking so that
exclusive with our U.S correspondent
James Matthews there who we hope to
speak to once we return from our break
so that was
Sky News at 10 coming up we'll take a
first look at tomorrow's newspapers in
the Press preview including this story
on the front of the mirror their
headline Phil
Affair storm tonight we're going to be
joined by daily Miracle Mist Susie
Boniface and Deputy comment editor at
the telegraph Annabelle Denham do stay
with us for more
[Music]
well this is Sky News in just a moment
the Press preview a first look at what's
on the front pages as they arrive
coming up in a moment but first the
former prime minister Boris Johnson has
spoken for the first time about further
allegations that he attended illegal
Gatherings during lockdown cabinet
office officials have sent details about
events held in checkers and Downing
Street after they reviewed Mr Johnson's
official diary
or James Matthews is that with us now
from Dallas airport in Washington
um and James you caught up with the
Prime Minister as he was leaving
Washington DC what did you glean in in
your most robust encounter with the
former prime minister
yeah robust would be the word Jillian I
have to say it's not been easy catching
up with bonus Johnson he has been on a
tour of the United States in Texas where
he met with Republicans influential
Republicans in that party's Heartland
had lunch with George W bush former
president then he went to Las Vegas
where he delivered a speech for which we
he was paid a reported six-figure sum
there was a media presence there he
managed to dodge that overnight last
night he had dinner with another former
president Donald Trump at his Golf Club
they spoke about Ukraine Boris Johnson
has been banging the drum here for
continued support for Ukraine in the
conflict with Russia but of course the
domestic issue that he cannot leave
behind is covet and his behavior during
covet I managed to put some questions
along with our team here at Dallas
airport as he caught the flight to
London with saying there's one due to to
leave quite soon and he spoke for the
first time about these allegations
allegations that
during lockdown when there were lockdown
restrictions and he should not have been
mingling with friends at Checkers and at
Downing Street he did so that would be a
breach of the regulations and of course
those alleged breaches have been uh
passed on to the relevant authorities
the police no less Thames Valley and
Metropolitan forces they've also been
leaked to the media so he is staring
down the Battle of fresh allegations of
having broken lockdown restrictions his
response to that is that it's nonsense
someone somewhere he told me is putting
this about effectively trying to stitch
him up now that phrase Stitch him up
that came from his office a couple of
days ago talking about this having all
the the Hallmarks or the makings of a
political stitch up that's one of the
questions I asked him who is stitching
you up the clear implication and talk of
a special being is coming from Richie
sunac and his wing of the conservative
party but he wouldn't be drawn into
details of who was behind the state shop
wouldn't be drawn into details of why
this is nonsense and why ministerial
Diaries do not indicate that he was
indeed mixing with friends when that
would have been unlawful I suppose the
detail of the allegations and his claims
of Innocence will come out in due course
at the covert public inquiry if nowhere
else but I think what we got from Boris
Johnson for the first time was his
emphatic denial we got his headline
denial the detail he wasn't prepared to
to go into but it's an indication I
think for you know this American trip
and everywhere Boris Johnson goes and in
everything that he does if he is perhaps
endeavoring to launch a political
comeback this is an indication the
headlines that have followed him
throughout this American trip an
indication that covert is the baggage he
cannot leave behind
yes sir James is the former prime
minister quite angry at times they're
saying the whole thing it's a load of
nonsense from beginning to end James
Matthews at Dallas airport in Dallas
thank you